bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i hope you guys
are all doing well i've got zach here
with me thank you so much for doing this
sir
thank you great to be on for sure let's
just jump right into it what is your
background and what did you do before
you got into a bitcoin crypto and uh
creating hardware for
the ecosystem yes so i'm a mechanical
engineer by background
um and then after school i was working
more on software product management
uh got into bitcoin back in 2013
and was lurking really for a few years
just working more normal jobs outside
the space
and then i ultimately uh jumped in to
the decentralized internet you know more
blockchain industry
in 2017 where i joined up um in one of
the first
uh roles with a company in boston called
nebulous making
uh saya the decentralized cloud storage
project we also did obelisk where we
were making
uh cryptocurrency asic miners and um
and so i worked full time in the space
from 2017
uh since and uh did everything from some
software related stuff but end up
spending most of my time
on hardware and on building these miners
and you know hardware is what i'm most
passionate about
you know i was always obsessed with like
apple for example since i was a little
kid and building computers and all that
and so it's just really exciting that we
started foundation devices back in april
of last year
and uh you know we're actually building
uh consumer-facing hardware for uh for
bitcoin and a decentralized internet
so what was the kind of impetus for a
starting foundation right was it
something
that uh in the previous work you were
doing you're like hey i gotta go do this
uh was it a specific product you know
just tell me the story is kind of how
you originally thought of like
we gotta go do this under uh the
foundation brand yeah so i think it was
a combination of
two things one was like a longer term
more mission oriented
and the other was a short term like we
want to make the specific product
so for the longer term it was that
we just fundamentally think that today's
hardware devices
um you know everything from the consumer
hardware the chips the operating system
the app stores
but they're just not really compatible
with bitcoin and the decentralized
internet
for a bunch of reasons you know they're
closed source they're proprietary
they oftentimes are hostile to use their
privacy
they try to control and restrict what
you can do on the different devices
and so we just knew that you know
thinking on like a 10-year time horizon
that we need to start a hardware company
that is focused on building hardware
that's compatible with
you know the space and then more of a
shorter term
and more like a practical approach
is that we've been using hardware
wallets for a long time
you know i remember back in 2013 2014
i was even before hardware wallets
existed i was storing my bitcoin on like
an air-gapped computer where i would
remove the wi-fi card and you know
transfer things with like thumb drives
back and forth
you know then started to use hardware
wallets like trezor and ledger and cold
card and one thing that we were shocked
about
was that uh most of the bitcoin was
stored with custodial providers
and we were trying to figure out you
know why is that
uh why are people not taking sovereignty
taking custody of their own bitcoin
their own cryptocurrencies
and you know like what's the core of the
problem and we basically just had this
gut feeling and uh kind of just knew
that it was a ux problem
and we thought that we could just make a
really like a
next generation hardware wallet to make
it uh much
easier to you know store your bitcoin
and uh also just more secure and to
hopefully
get all those coins into user hands
because the space only works if people
have sovereignty
and if people are actually storing their
own keys so we set off to make this
product called passport
this new hardware wallet which we're on
track to ship by the end of march
and at the same time we're just kind of
planning out this longer term product
roadmap and figuring out
you know how do we provide devices
that give people sovereignty why do the
hardware wallet first like
what was the logic behind that specific
product
so one is i think we thought that
we just had this really crazy sense of
urgency um
you know we were working as employees
and this was you know
back in we started talking about this
more back in 2019
and then early 2020 came around and
uh you know the having and all that and
obviously the pandemic started and we
were just saying to each other
like there's going to be a new a new
bull market and if we go through another
bull market
without like a hardware wallet that
could appeal to a larger mass
of consumers then all of these coins
might end up on
coinbase or other exchanges and look i
mean obviously there's nothing wrong
with
exchanges um that's currently the
on-ramps in order to you know move your
fiat into bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies
but we really just didn't want to go
through a cycle where you know i think
it's like oh i think coinbase has
like over a million bitcoin uh in
custody right now
uh for themselves than for other funds
and other you know providers
and we're like is it going to be like
you know 2 million 3 million by the end
of this new bull market like what's that
gonna look like so we just felt this
crazy urgency to start there
and then also just practically we knew
exactly what we needed to do to make
this product
there aren't any you know we weren't
restricted by like manpower we weren't
restricted by capital
uh we knew what we wanted to make for
this gen 1 device and we knew that we
could bring it to market
in less than a year when if we were
looking at
other devices we weren't sure you know
if there's a market for them
if there's enough demand they might be
more expensive to develop or even much
more
expensive or difficult on the software
side so we just figured like
rather than be that startup that raises
like all this capital and it doesn't
ship anything for years
like let's raise a little bit of capital
and then let's ship something in less
than a year
uh and so that's what we're doing i love
that approach of just
get it out there right but make sure
it's good uh so you have this
differentiated approach in terms of the
actual
product that you're building compared to
maybe some of the other hardware
providers talk a little bit about how
you
see uh the existing landscape and then
kind of what you guys are doing
differently
yeah definitely so there's a couple
things about us that are a little bit
different
and what we're trying to do is make the
best combination of security
user experience and then also just
general kind of product design and feel
so that it feels like a really great uh
product
um so you know on the security side
um everything we do is open source and
so the hardware designs the hardware
schematics
you could actually go download like our
circuit board design files and see how
the board is made see what components
are used
then obviously all the firmware which is
the software that runs on the device is
also
open source so that's really important
because you know bitcoin is open source
uh if you're trusting us as a company
you probably want to know what the
device is doing
um and so some some hardware wallet
makers you know like ledger are not
open source and so that hardware
represents more of a black box and
you can trust the company and that's
totally fine but
that's kind of the model that we have
currently we don't think that's the
right model for
this new you know bitcoin power
decentralized internet so the open
source is important to us
however we're also using a security chip
which is called the secure element um
which makes it
you know much more secure so like trezor
is a great example of an open source
hardware wallet uh
their hardware and their firmware is
also open source
but because they don't use a security
chip you can extract the private keys in
like
15 minutes usually with with commonly
available hardware and
kraken has done some good uh posts about
that and so
you know that's that's okay as long as
you uh you know keep your treasure in a
secure location or use a passphrase or
something
but we think that you know we want to
try to take the open source and then
combine it with that
you know extra layer of security very
similar to what cold card has been doing
on the bitcoin
side of things and um but we also wanted
just to make it really easy to use
uh make it look like a you know a a
really nice device that's intuitive
you know you shouldn't have to enter
your pin number with two buttons right
like how do you enter an eight-digit pin
with two buttons
for example um you should just know how
to use the device from the second you
power it on
and then we also really wanted to
encourage like
fast use and best security practices
and so uh we use an a full air gap
uh with a camera and qr codes is the
primary way of transacting
and that's what makes us really
different from the this existing
generation of hardware devices
where instead of having to go to your
computer you know plug the usb
cable into your hardware wallet take a
few minutes to like
open up the software and and send
everything you can just within like five
seconds
scan a qr code from your phone click the
button and passport to sign that
transaction
then scan the qr code back and you're
done and so what used to be like a few
minute process where you have to go to
the computer
becomes like a really really fast and
secure process
that is a mobile first it of course
works too with desktop computers either
with like an sd card or
a webcam but we're really trying to make
it mobile first
and the cool thing about that is you
know and another way that we're
different in approach
is that our goal is like mass
compatibility with every popular
software wallet and service so whether
that's like
casa blue wallet you know unchained
capital hopefully even working with
exchanges at some point
the idea that you can like withdraw your
bitcoin
into cold storage but you don't have to
leave
that existing user interface that you're
in and so you can kind of move coins
back and forth but you can
use passport as this like air gap ultra
secure signing device
um and it really changes the idea of a
hardware wallet where the vast majority
of people who are buying
you know ledger or trezor devices are
relying on that ledger or trezor
software
so we don't even make a software wallet
you know we just make the hardware
wallet we're making sure it's compatible
with all of the different you know
popular bitcoin wallets
and uh and then we're just gonna you
know keep making the experience uh
easier and easier
so there's a lot of people who are going
to watch this they're going to say why
is open source so important
right like i get it people always talk
about it but why is it especially in the
bitcoin world why is the open source
component so important
i think before bitcoin it was just not
that important
right before bitcoin open source was
something that you would expect to see
for like especially on the hardware side
you'd expect to see like
very developer oriented products like
you know bare circuit boards and stuff
as
open source more for like the hacker or
the the hobbyist community
but bitcoin really changes that i think
the most practical example is like
you know if you make a credit card
transaction today
and there's some kind of fraud uh it's
not that big of a deal
because you just contact your bank and
then just reverse that transaction
obviously in bitcoin transactions are
immutable
and so there is such a higher likelihood
that there's
uh could be theft or could be mistakes
that could cause the loss of your coins
and as the bitcoin market cap grows
uh it actually incentivizes um
bad behavior because all it takes is
like you know a single
rogue employee or something at a company
making
uh you know a hardware wallet or some
other device that's throwing your
bitcoin
to maybe insert some kind of backdoor or
some kind of vulnerability in there
and then your coins could be gone and so
hardware is really hard
because there's always like you're
always in a sense trusting the company
that you're buying from
unless you're building it yourself from
scratch
but there's a lot that we as the
hardware maker can do
to assure users that you know we didn't
just throw this crap thing together and
then release it
and then keep everything closed source
we're open sourcing all of our work so
that you can look at it
you know you can audit it you can see
how it works you can see if we've made
any mistakes in it
you know there's a really huge community
of security researchers in the bitcoin
space
that are constantly finding
vulnerabilities with hardware wallets
today
and that'll scale up as we you know we
and other companies make other devices
whether it's
you know laptops or phones or other
things in the future
um and so just the the auditability
uh and the open and transparent security
is really important and that's exactly
how bitcoin works right the bitcoin core
software
is completely open source and it would
have never succeeded
if the software was was closed source
and you didn't know how it worked
and then there's this one other aspect
that maybe is a little bit more like
like a higher level that we think is
important but just that
like why there's been so little progress
in the physical world compared to the
digital world
it seems like everything in the software
world um
really builds on top of these core open
source components
you know if you're building a new app
you're not starting from scratch
right you're you're going to github and
you're finding all these different open
source components and you're integrating
it into these libraries you're
integrating it into your app
that doesn't exist in hardware you know
you're almost always starting from
scratch when you go to make
a new hardware device and so we kind of
hope as like a secondary benefit
that we can help lower the entry to
other companies that are looking to make
hardware
then if we're building on the same kind
of like hardware libraries or hardware
designs then
if those designs have really been put
under the microscope by security
researchers
it gives consumers more confidence that
like this hardware is secure
and like you look at most companies
today it's so difficult to make even
like a security chip like
apple's t2 chip that was in all the
previous macbooks
for the last few years it's completely
just
it's completely broken right like you
can you can and and so what we think is
like
if apple can't get it to work right if
they have a chip that's been in
computers for years that just
you can plug in a thunderball cable and
bypass the security chip
um why do we as a small startup of four
people think that we're gonna do
you know any better so by doing things
in the open it hopefully will make it
just
much more secure in the long run so
speaking of apple
uh i think a lot of people when they
think of open source software they say
you know hey there's a security element
there's an ethos element but the user
experience sucks right or the user
interface is stuck
it's kind of uh counter-intuitive right
because you're optimizing versus
everything else other than that
i think you've got this thought process
though that you can build open source
hardware or software and you can make it
just as competitive
from the beauty and the elegance and the
simplicity that uh an
apple-like product would have so let me
talk a little bit about how you see the
balance between
open source software and then the user
experiences that people today in the
consumer internet have come to expect
yeah like as much as we're defining
ourselves as an open source
hardware company that that isn't like
it's that's not our main
like uh attribute right and it's almost
like that we're trying to make
uh beautiful really easy to use hardware
for bitcoin and decentralized internet
that also happens to be
completely open source and that might be
a little different than
you know when you usually think open
source hardware it's usually like
developed or created for this uh
community
that doesn't care at all what it looks
like doesn't care at all about the user
interfaces it's usually developers
who want to buy like a linux laptop or
want to tinker with like a linux
smartphone or something like the pine
phone for example which is getting kind
of popular in the developer circles
you know that bitcoin kind of fixes the
incentives here
and uh for the first time ever
gives normal everyday consumers a reason
to want to buy an open source device
it's like
if you're comparing two identical
devices let's say we in the future were
able to make
a smartphone that was identical to the
iphone in terms of most metrics right
and then you know you're going to use it
to store bitcoin on there
are you gonna buy the closed source one
that's maybe made in china you know buy
or you're gonna buy the open source one
that maybe is made in the us
i think if you kind of level that
playing field and you introduce bitcoin
into the equation
all of the sudden you put value on the
open source hardware
because you know that it probably has a
security model
that is more transparent and potentially
you know more secure because so many
eyes are on it
and that kind of goes along with what i
just said earlier
so i think the main thing is that at
least the way we look at it
and maybe even i personally look at it
is like i never really cared about open
source hardware before bitcoin
right like apple fanatic my first job
out of high school was in the apple
store
you know all those apple devices and
when i first got into bitcoin i didn't
really care much about it either i was
like oh bitcoin's just gonna replace the
banks and the trusted third parties
but now you know thanks to all the
different podcasts
and guests that are on like on yours and
others you know stefan lovera tales from
the crypt and all those
um i've gotten much more about it's all
about the sovereignty angle it's about
giving people sovereignty over their
lives
um and because of that i just feel like
uh the open source hardware where the
hardware maker doesn't try to control
what the user does on their device
the hardware maker gives the users
privacy the hardware maker
doesn't try to hide or obfuscate how the
device works or how the os
works it's all out there um
there's now a reason to buy that kind of
hardware and maybe before bitcoin
that reason did not exist for sure
and so you we talked a little bit about
apple but there's also google and i know
that you've got some thoughts around
this like duopoly and how
uh apple and google may actually be uh
disincentivizing or putting obstacles up
uh in terms of bitcoin bitcoin adoption
yeah devices like how do you think about
that duopoly what do you think the
challenges are and how do we kind of get
around them
yeah i actually think that this is going
to be
the biggest challenge to mass adoption
of bitcoin and to decentralize internet
over the next few years because
we're getting really close to the point
where i think this tech is going to go
mainstream
and we're seeing all these really really
cool applications
um whether you're a bitcoin maximalist
or or not
i mean i think a really great example
that i like to use
is um you know brian armstrong or
coinbase that did a tweet storm a few
months back
about how apple forced them to remove
the dapp store
from the coinbase app that's really bad
right and you know a bitcoiner might say
haha you know it's a it's a dapp store
you know
who cares whatever but i think if
if a company is trying to you know in
this case apple which is kind of acting
as the gatekeeper is trying to get
involved
and restrict what kind of applications
you can run on your device
our entire industry is about building
these new business models right
streaming payments smart contracts
machine to machine payments
you know being able to you know uh
automatically get rewarded with bitcoin
in a game
you know being able to automatically
maybe if you read an article or listen
to a podcast then you can kind of stream
bitcoin back to that content creator
there's all these like crazy cool
business models that i think are
unlocked by this whole new industry
and the existing duopoly you know apple
and google
do not allow those business models to
exist on their devices
apple is obviously a bit more strict
than google
um but google too i mean google has you
know banned metamask multiple times
um they've removed uh popular open
source
applications from their app store and it
seems like
censorship is just on the rise and these
companies are constantly removing
everything and sometimes they get ready
back
right but i think there's this idea of
these companies have a direct incentive
to
at least for now uh fight against
adoption of
bitcoin and decentralized internet if
you look at how they make their money
right google is all about collecting
your data and then targeting you with
advertising
that's like its purest most simple form
so they have no interest in giving users
any kind of privacy
um whatsoever on their devices their
entire model is about
you know capturing that data and they've
also doubled down
you know on their app store uh it you
can side load apps into android but you
like going to the developer settings and
it's pretty scary there's no easy way to
like install a separate app store on
android right now
and then apple um you know apple
has been uh increasing the amount of
revenue that they make from services
over the last few years where i think
it's over a quarter of their revenue now
comes from services
and another enormous part of the revenue
actually comes from a search deal with
google which most people don't talk
about
and so apple has this uh strong
incentive to extract as much value as
possible from their current customers
because that's the only way that apple
grows without selling more devices and
they're kind of running out of people
to sell devices to at this point you
know it's like
they can make you know maybe they'll
make an ar headset or something continue
to expand the market or like with
airpods or other things like that
but if you start to look at what they've
been doing with all the different
service plays
and then doubling down on you know the
app store like for example with their
public battles with epic games the
makers of fortnite
and then others um they really want to
just capture a share of all that revenue
on ios and how can they do that if
uh you know developers want to start
integrating bitcoin into all of their
different products right into
their different applications and so we
look at it as
you know maybe i think that maybe the
only way these companies will come
around is if they
hold a lot of bitcoin maybe in their in
their treasury right and then there's a
strong incentive over time to change
those business models in order to
accommodate this this whole new internet
i don't think we're there yet
and so i think we'll see over the next
couple years more of these public stats
applications that you know developers
want to launch but they're not allowed
to launch
and um that's top of mind for us as we
think about you know what hardware we
want to build next
yeah how do you think that this plays
into like just decentralized internet in
general right we talked a lot about
bitcoin and kind of
some of their hardware and business
models but like does that also
disincentivize the adoption of the
decent
decentralized internet because it
essentially kind of cuts off what they
deem most valuable
i think it does i think um one of the
things when you're building a
decentralized internet is
you want people to store their own keys
and you want them to run their own
infrastructure
those are like the two big things and
that's when we think about the products
that we make you know those
are like the those are the two things
that are top of mind and so
none of our devices today are built
around the idea
of users running their own
infrastructure everything is
cloud-based right you're using apple's
cloud services or google's cloud
services
and that's just part of the device it's
like integrated at the operating system
level
and it's very hard to opt out without
degrading your user experience
significantly
so if we want consumers actually running
their own nodes
you know running their own uh you know
applications essentially
we need to provide them with a different
type of product than the types of
products that are being made by the
existing
you know hardware players and we need to
provide them with you know an
operating system that is designed to be
able to communicate
back to like maybe their hosted
infrastructure and
or self-hosted infrastructure and you
know
i i just think that
i think that you know with with
especially with google and apple with
just the cloud storage element
i think that um that's just not how you
that's not how you build a decentralized
internet uh and then there's this
practical approach like on ios 2 with uh
you know you're not even allowed to run
applications in the background on ios
so like how do you have how do you have
a node or even if it's not a node like
how do you have an application that is
you know listening for communications
with
other applications running in the
background on ios
like some kind of smart contract or
something or even a
bitcoin wallet that is uh able to give
you a push notification when a
transaction comes in
if you don't have a centralized server
it's actually really hard to do
the blue wallet guys actually had to
make their own server
that you can run yourself if you want
but 99 of people just rely on bluewall
it's hosted server
to be able to serve you with a push
notification when a transaction comes in
so it gets like that granular you know
it's it's things that you don't expect
it's all these restrictions start to add
up and then you're like wait a minute
like how do i actually run these
applications on a phone i can run them
on a computer i can run them on a
raspberry pi
but how do i run them on like you know a
phone absolutely
give us a kind of an overview it's like
what is the product suite that you have
today
and then let's talk about kind of where
you think you'll go next in terms of
what's on the horizon or on the roadmap
so today
um we have one product and that's uh
that's passport
and passport you know our goal for
passport is to uh
be the best key manager
and personal security device that you
can have and we're almost trying to
create a new category of device
i think right now you know you have um
you have a hardware wallet
and uh we've seen some of the hardware
while companies like trezor
do some cool stuff with you know making
it a uh fido token
you know or uh using it as like a
password manager
um and i think it works but it's it's
very early in that implementation so
we're interested in taking passport
which right now is just a bitcoin
hardware wallet
and growing it into more of like your
hardware wallet
your password manager the place where
you put your 2fa codes it's really easy
when you have a camera to be able to you
know
save those 2fa codes on the device and
you know
basically allow it to become like your
ultra secure air-gapped personal
security device
and that's going to be really good as
more and more things move to be private
key based
that's one of those other restrictions
on the current platforms which is like
everything is based on email and
password
as we move from email and password to
private
and public keys um we're gonna need to
be able to give users a better way to
manage those keys and so passport
becomes
you know that air gapped device um
and then for future devices i don't know
how much i want to talk about it uh but
we're aiming for
um the next product to be a uh
like a a node product um
but rather than being built with a
raspberry pi it's you know built
completely
from scratch with all open source
hardware with a screen an integrated
hardware wallet a camera
so that not only can you like run your
own self-hosted applications at home
but you can use your node as like a
hardware wallet
and it starts to get really interesting
as if you think like
when you think hardware wallet you think
like ultra secure maybe air gaps maybe
not internet connected
but we think of it more as like every
device
is essentially going to serve as a
hardware wallet um it's just that
there's going to be different levels of
security for these devices
so the idea that you could have like a
bitcoin multisig setup
with you know like your phone uh a node
that sits on your desk or shelf at home
and then
a hardware wallet we think is a really
really cool future
and that you can kind of uh run your
self-hosted applications yourself and
kind of one-click install those with an
app store so
that's the next thing that we're working
towards and then we're also starting to
work on the architecture and
um you know also uh raise more capital
to be able to pursue
a phone which we think is kind of like
the holy grail
and incredibly important um to
uh building this this new internet and
thinking about
doing it where it's all based around um
you know private keys for the with a
bitcoin wallet as almost part of the os
because imagine being able to you know
really easily and frictionlessly
buy apps with bitcoin uh make in-app
purchases in bitcoin
stream payments and do all these other
kinds of things that
you just can't do on this current
generation of hardware devices
then of course as we build all this
everything we do is open source the
hardware and the software
and as we make revenue we're hoping to
be able to reinvest that
that capital into the lower layers of
the stack
things like making uh chips that are
open source and more secure
um doing uh you know vertically
integrating our manufacturing so that
we're actually owning our own facilities
we're making these products
a lot of those types of things that
didn't really matter before bitcoin
now matter and so we're really thinking
a lot about the components we're using
how do we use components that are more
trustable how do we make our own
maybe it's not a you know a whole
processor at first maybe it's just
we make an open source touchscreen
controller chip so you know that you can
trust your touchscreen better
you know and then we you know we're
we're owning our own facility you know
here locally in the us and we're able to
make that ourselves without relying on
trusting other people so we're looking
at at
really uh addressing this entire layer
of like the physical
stack yeah what do you think is going to
be the biggest challenge
between here and like building some of
the stuff you're talking about there
is it just time is it money is it
something kind of from an ecosystem
standpoint
uh is it regulatory what do you think is
the biggest challenge
i think that there's definitely
definitely a money component i think is
probably the biggest challenge
and then i think there's also just uh
building a community and ecosystem
uh component right to it you know as we
make these devices
and it's really important to say this
our early devices are not going to be as
good
as the existing generation of devices
from like an apple
in the beginning right we're going to be
better in other areas
we're going to be able to provide users
with freedom uh with sovereignty with
control with privacy
and be able to do all this stuff as open
source um
but it's really really hard to directly
compete with that apple level ux
because so much of it relies on
centralized infrastructure
and also just having the you know the
capital to be able to make these
these custom chips and other things that
apple can do that are you know
the best in the world right now so we're
going to be not as good in some areas
and we're going to be really i think
better in other areas
and then over time we'll get better in
all the areas but i think it's going to
require a community of early adopters
that is willing to maybe trade off
certain things we trade off a little bit
of speeder performance
be willing to um you know trade off the
camera quality because it's like
most companies can't make i don't think
any company can make a cell phone camera
you know as good as as
good as it's on the iphone so it's going
to require users that are willing to
accept those trade-offs
uh in return for greater sovereignty and
control over their lives
and then hopefully if we get enough of
those users
then we'll be able to have enough
capital to just
really easily close the gap in those
other areas
yeah absolutely uh before we get into
the rapid fire questions to wrap up
uh if somebody wants to learn more about
the device uh where can they go to it to
learn more or potentially purchase one
um you can go to foundationdevices.com
and you can learn more about passport on
there and we're doing a coupon code uh
pomp for uh ten dollars off your uh your
order
oh amazing yes people use the coupon
code pomp
at foundationdevices.com they'll get uh
some money off
yep exactly amazing you had to think for
a second about foundationdevices.com i
was worried for a second
i was like maybe he's got some complex
secret uh url we don't know about we
have many urls no i'm just i'm just
kidding
i was i was already thinking towards the
rapid fire questions
all right so here we go three of them
and you'll get to ask me one to uh to
finish up first is what's the most
important book that you've ever
read the fountainhead
why i think that
the protagonist there um who's an
architect
and this is obviously not the the most
popular iron ran book right usually
everyone goes for atlas shrugged or
something
but i think the protagonist is is uh
looking to create in this book you know
buildings
uh that are completely unlike everything
else out there
and he's ridiculed you know basically
his entire career over it and he's
willing to
he he's unwilling to compromise on his
principles
and because he believes so much in his
principles
and he knows what he's doing is right
that he's willing to kind of take that
societal ridicule until he ultimately
you know find some success later on um
so it's crazy the amount of uh
i don't know if i want to say almost
like the amount of pain that that this
you know individual can endure in order
to
you know stick to their stick to their
guns so uh really amazing book and also
just very design oriented and i i like
all that kind of
design stuff i love it uh second
question a little bit more personal
sleep schedule and this comes to us from
our friends over at eight sleep uh i
sleep on their thermoregulated bed it's
like an
ice cube uh i used to sleep six hours
now like eight or nine hours
i feel amazing my wife says i'm way less
cranky
and just a better human being in general
uh
what is your sleep schedule and how has
that evolved over the years
uh it's a total mess right now
[Laughter]
because uh we got wrong answer we got a
new puppy
um uh about a month and a half ago
and so puppies and kids are the two
answers people are like yeah it's not
going so hot right now those tend to be
the the uh
culprits yeah i'm currently i you know
we like doing work late at night and so
i'm usually up till like 1am or
something and
it's not working because the puppy wakes
us up at you know 6 30 and so
i'm uh trying to shift my
uh schedule to be earlier so i was very
proud to go to bed
at uh before midnight last night
the puppy is changing your life but i am
interested in trying some of these um
uh smart you know mattresses and stuff
and i've noticed too that i'm big on the
cold exposure and
to do like a cold shower before bed i
sleep much better
yeah eight sleep is the best one
obviously you know they forget all the
other ones
uh next uh question is uh aliens are you
a believer or a non-believer
total believer why um and uh
i i think after uh diving into
um the tic tac stuff i
i've really gone off the deep end in
that uh thank you uh
i think mike solano right was was he on
your podcast
um yeah i believe i listened to that
episode after reading one of his posts
and
since then i've gone way down the deep
end over the last
um maybe six months or so and uh and i'm
constantly just looking out my window
over the
you know boston skyline saying you know
am i going to see something darting
around
up there hopefully all right so maybe
one day
i don't want to take any credit for
making mike solana
converts on this podcast but i will say
that you and a couple of other people
have specifically
i listened to that podcast and i did
whatever
whether it was go read more of his stuff
you know something he said on it or too
much
too much he may need a
an invite back at some point because he
he came on and
he did not hold back which which i
always appreciate uh but i am a believer
as well as you already know
uh i don't know if you're gonna see a
tic tac over the boston skyline but if
you see one
uh the thing i keep telling people is uh
take a picture
that's what drives all my skepticism
because i watch the documentaries and i
i try to
listen to other podcasts but they can
get a little too strange they get a
little too weird right
and so um my the biggest complaint is
why is there not more
uh video or photo evidence it's 20 21
like come on guys
um but we'll see i definitely i
definitely do believe it now
so we will not see a headline zach
herbert leads the charge to uh storm
area 51
but uh he will have his camera ready i
think i think the right thing to do is
instead
i feel like if i actually like if i took
a year off and i want to just go
find the stuff i would go hang out at
like the military bases and
and nuclear bases you know hang around
there because that seems to be where
there's a lot of strangeness happening
um
so i just go you know go camp out like
as close as you can get to the nuclear
facility right before without getting
arrested
and see what happens maybe maybe one day
but i don't think
i don't think we'll be having any time
off uh in the near future working on the
startup
i i completely agree what one question
you have for me to uh to finish up
yeah just kind of in theme of what we're
doing um
i'm curious what you think of kind of
self-custody
um for institutions because that's
something that i know nothing about
my sense is you know a lot more about
how it works on the back end there and
we think so much about self-custody for
individuals but it's obvious that all
these institutions are just going right
to some custodial providers i'm curious
what you think
what you think we need in order for the
institutions to actually hold their
bitcoin themselves so i'll give you an
anecdotal uh
joke that i used to use which was when i
would talk to the institutions i would
say hey listen and by the way you know
we're going to put
15 20 of the fund into uh bitcoin but
just so you know
we're not going to be uh having me walk
around the office with like a usb
stick in my pocket right and the whole
idea was it was basically a joke on hey
listen
you need to understand that uh there's
kind of a
cover your ass right a career de-risking
of like
i'm not holding on to the bitcoin i'm
not gonna run away with the bitcoin like
there's some other
a qualified custodian or whatever so a
lot of it is less about like do they
feel
technically capable of doing it um or do
they have an appetite for it it's more
so just a complete cover your ass
de-risk
from a career perspective uh and so
that's where qualified custodians
and investment mandates and things like
that come in a lot of the uh
external third-party due diligence
processes and checklists and
that now with all that said that was me
being overly kind and excusing why they
want to do it
uh i have yet to meet a institution
there might be individuals at an
institution but an institution in
general that is ready to do self-custody
uh they're not informed enough they
don't have technical capabilities they
don't have
kind of all the things that you would
need in order to do it with any level of
success especially if there was a
material amount of their
uh fund exposed to bitcoin or some other
asset
and so i think we are like really really
far away from
the kind of um average institution to do
it
what might happen first is you might get
some hedge funds that converted to
family offices or somebody like that who
they're kind of acting as like large
individuals right but they're still kind
of an organization
uh they'll probably be the first to do
it and then eventually you'll kind of
get it to go through the um
uh through the um you know kind of
wonderful
i will say though that anyone who's
acting on a fiduciary duty so
pensions endowments that type of stuff i
just never see them doing it
uh because they don't do it with any
other asset it's not a bitcoin thing
it's just any asset
uh and it's just pure like i don't want
to get fired i don't want to
you know have them come with pitchforks
and tell me how you know i lost the
bitcoin because we self-custody did
i forgot where i put it or i got the
seed or whatever
right makes sense so hopefully hopefully
that'll change and
we're hoping that we can in the future
make some products to help standardize
that but i think you're right it's
it's super early there and it's just
great to see them buying bitcoin at all
and uh hopefully a lot more of them do
that's uh that's the way i look at it at
least
uh zach where can we send people to find
you on the internet or reach out if they
got more questions
uh easiest place to just i'm zach
herbert on twitter
um pretty active on twitter so that's
the best place to go
so am i my friend so am i i'm aware
awesome man listen thank you so much for
doing this i'm a huge fan of what you
guys are doing i think
that uh we just need more people
building this stuff so keep going we're
we're big fans and we'll have to do it
again in the future cool thanks so much
thanks for having me on